in the christmas spirit is teen
sensation
jojo siwa neve i know your daughter cleo
might be a little young but do you think
she will one day be a
sea one eater oh absolutely i mean
cleo's only four but she already loves
glam and she wears her big bows so she's
super into it oh if she loves the bow
she's ready
now only e.t talked to jojo and got an
exclusive look inside her
winter wonderland
[Music]
hey e.t i'm jenna siwa and welcome to my
house during the holidays
you can see we have our staircase that
is full of bows because you know me i'm
jojo i love bows
we have our magical unicorn rainbow
force
okay we have 16 christmas trees we are
the type that are like
november 1st it is time to put up a
christmas tree it's christmas
it took more than a week to deck the
halls of jojo's 3.4 million dollar
la mansion where the 17 year old lives
with her mom dad and brother
hello welcome to the old-fashioned
christmas room this is typically what
our candy bar is but we have transformed
it to be an
old fashioned christmas room this santa
too we actually have had for
so long and this is our dining room
now we are in i think the best room of
the house normally this is considered
our living room this tree's like
our black and white almost like gwen
stefani ice cream candy vibes
the pop star slash dancer slash glitter
fanatic is
super active on social media with her
millions of fans
her youtube videos have 3.4 billion
views
and two weeks ago she shared she was
feeling sicky sick but turns out it was
way more than a common cold
i did end up getting it uh
the the big breaded the big dreaded
coven 19 it got it got through my whole
family we had headaches we were tired we
had shortness of breath we had all the
things all my family actually lost their
taste and smell
uh but i'll have it back but i never did
where are you
well you did have a recent change in
your life i know that you and
your boyfriend broke up
i'm single as a pringle right now but
mark and i did break up we were together
for
for three months it was great we had fun
you know we drove through taco bell i
think
450 times he had to kind of
do some things in his life he deserves
nothing but greatness
i feel you christmas
yeah it's pretty clear jojo loves the
holiday
and it makes perfect sense that she just
dropped a new ep
jojo's rocking christmas and the music
video for it's christmas now
the idea for this music video is that we
are all gingerbread
people i know i'm not playing beyond i
know i'm not kelly clarkson but
i'm jojo and you know i got the
six-year-olds that love it that's all
that matters